so what do you want like if you were to
look at your life you know because the
other criticism that will come to you if
it hasn't already is like people will
say well sure she's talking about
traditional roles but here she is with
this successful YouTube channel and
she's an entrepreneur in her own right
and what do you say to people say oh my
gosh I thought it was going to be a
hobby this took up fast and why why did
you think it blew up like that oh um
well I was posting more than everyone
else so and I just I actually was funny
I got out of a relationship and I was
kind of sad so I was like I'm gonna just
make a show and then all this will like
distract me you know
um and then yeah I just started doing
the show I mean what do I say to that I
would say
um look it I'm looking so oh Pearl's
looking in the chat in case you're in
there we're gonna get to the chat in
just a second I think sometimes people
will be like oh why aren't you married
today tomorrow and I'm like look it I'm
I'm learning to cook I'm talking to
wives I'm doing the best that I can
you're doing the work I'm like I'm doing
the best I can